[Música]
y
la noche del 24 de febrero tanques y
tropas rusas invadieron el territorio
ucraniano
específicamente en la región del donbass
en donde ya había un conflicto abierto
desde el 2014 el argumento de moscú fue
que llevaba a cabo esta operación
militar especial por las amenazas que
representaba el gobierno que había en el
poder o que hay en el poder en kiev y
las aspiraciones de ese país de entrar a
la otan pero tiempo después el
presidente vladimir putin afirmó que
todo hacía parte de una estrategia para
forzar un cambio de orden mundial
escuchemos
pero me gustaría señalar que ya han
perdido desde el comienzo de nuestra
operación militar especial
el
comienzo de la misma significa el
comienzo de un colapso fundamental del
orden mundial en el estilo
estadounidense este es el comienzo de la
transición del egocentrismo americano
globalista liberal a un mundo
verdaderamente multipolar distrito el
único pelear no miedo
de qué se trata entonces ese nuevo orden
mundial qué papel quiere jugar rusia y
qué papel quiere jugar el presidente
putin en ese nuevo escenario lo cierto
es que por el momento parece que la
estrategia de rusia está ganando terreno
poco a poco en qué sentido han
conquistado buena parte del este de
ucrania han proclamado o ha ayudado a
proclamar la independencia de dos
repúblicas populares done jets y lugansk
europa prácticamente está en jaque a
nivel energético por el suministro de
gas y eso que el invierno todavía no ha
comenzado en el viejo continente y el
mundo también está al borde de una
hambruna gracias a las sanciones
internacionales que pesan sobre la
economía rusa lo que no permite que el
resto de los países puedan comprar
fertilizantes rusos eso entonces que
provoca pues que vaya a ver en unos
pocos meses unas malas cosechas y ni qué
decir pues del bloqueo que tiene rusia a
las exportaciones de granos y de
cereales ucranianos y de los puertos en
el mar negro el mundo entero se está
viendo afectado por este conflicto y por
estas aspiraciones rusas de una u otra
manera está el presidente putin entonces
logrando poner al mundo de rodillas a
estas declaraciones de intentar
conformar todo este nuevo orden mundial
por supuesto también se pronunció el
presidente de eeuu joe biden durante su
gira por medio oriente estas fueron sus
palabras
no estéis en ictus de canchis ground el
seibo
eeuu y cada uno de los países alrededor
de esta mesa son una parte esencial de
ese orden porque rechazamos la fuerza
bruta para cambiar las fronteras cuando
todo el consejo de cooperación para los
estados árabes del golfo más egipto y
jordania votaron en la asamblea general
de las naciones unidas para condenar la
invasión rusa ucrania fue un momento
decisivo
y
demostró que los valores fundamentales
de soberanía e integridad territorial
son verdaderamente universales y quiero
ser claro apoyar un orden basado en
normas no significa que siempre tengamos
que estar de acuerdo en todas las
cuestiones pero significa que nos
alineamos en torno a los principios
básicos que nos permiten trabajar juntos
en los desafíos globales más urgentes
pershing woods aun entonces preguntas en
ese orden mundial como concibe las
cargas políticas cuál es el balance que
quiere hacer el presidente putin es un
modelo en donde la democracia y las
libertades son garantes porque rusia
claramente no es el principal exponente
de democracia y de garantías de libertad
es en realidad ya prácticamente nadie lo
es a nivel mundial pero hay matices
digámoslo en ese nuevo rompecabezas y
equilibrios de fuerzas a nivel mundial
que quiere hacer putin donde queda china
donde queda américa latina que tanto de
esto es un discurso de propaganda de
estrategia por parte del kremlin
o es un gran plan a gran escala con una
durabilidad en el tiempo hoy en el
debate de france 24 está vladimir putin
provocando un nuevo orden mundial para
analizar este tema saludamos a la llosa
si él es analista de relaciones
internacionales y estudios estratégicos
de fuerzas terrestres navales aéreas y
espaciales rusas es también profesor
adjunto de la universidad interamericana
en la isla de puerto rico precisamente
se encuentra allí en la ciudad de san
juan ya esta conversación se une desde
tartu en estonia se une y van cleef csic
él es analista internacional e
investigador de la universidad de tanto
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen todas sus preguntas y
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde nos encuentran como
arroba france24
y arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
la etiqueta para que dejen sus
comentarios es numeral el debate efe 24
en youtube también pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming saludo también a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que ya están
disponibles en app el podcast en spotify
deezer y tienen
pues muy bien doy inicio entonces al
programa saludando a la diosa al día en
la ciudad de san juan en puerto rico y
haciéndole la primera pregunta como
punto de partida para conocer posiciones
de los invitados layos bienvenido al
programa gracias por estar con nosotros
y le parece a usted entonces que la
estrategia del presidente putin está
dando frutos poco a poco está
consiguiendo esa ruptura de un orden
mundial como lo ha llamado él
bueno hay una situación ciertamente de
guerra de conflicto que iniciándose en
ucrania tiene como ustedes pues que
están mencionando unas consecuencias a
nivel global no la subida de los precios
de los alimentos la carestía de los
granos y por ejemplo ucranianos y
también rusos el tema de la subida a los
precios de la energía etcétera pero yo
diría que en todo caso
es una reafirmó reafirmación por un lado
el lado geopolítico en eeuu está
logrando de momento el que haya una
mayor colaboración
euroatlántica en cuanto a la alianza
atlántica ha aumentado de número suecia
finlandia hasta los suizos la opinión
pública está interesada en colaborar más
con la otan en la unión europea ha
adoptado un frente común estrechas
relaciones con eeuu grupos de los 7
australia japón por ejemplo no en el
pacífico corea del sur
así que por un lado en el lado
geopolítico creo que es un desastre
hasta cierto punto para rusia y
estratégico en lo militar en lo militar
o puramente están empantanados los rusos
en ucrania el plan de pronuncia era
rápidamente ganar en pocos días y
mientras más se alarga esta guerra es
militarmente le va a ir peor a rusia
porque una cosa es que rusia esté
cobrando más ganando más dinero por la
subida los precios del petróleo el gas y
le está vendiendo mucho a la china mucho
a la india - obviamente a europa pero
otra cosa es la condición de las fuerzas
militares se están quedando sin equipo
militar moderno se están quedando sin
tropas también tendrían que hacer una
leva masiva que al parecer no han
querido hacer porque no lo declaran como
una guerra formal incluso entonces a eso
pues se estrecha los lazos de rusia y de
china se echan los brazos de rusia irán
o sea yo diría que por un lado hay una
nueva bipolaridad
geopolítica occidente por un lado
y lo que llamaría el bloque euroasiático
continental rusia china corea del norte
irán siria y claro pues la india es
digamos que neutral pero se entiende
pues con la de rusia también así que
tenemos esa división del mundo así que
es reafirmar unas fisuras que ya
existían pero que se hacen más
prominentes por esta guerra claro el
años pero ahora la palabra a iván en la
ciudad de tartu en estonia a punto de
partida y van bienvenido al programa
gracias por acompañarnos nuevamente le
parece a usted que esta estrategia está
poco a poco ganando terreno ese intento
de esa ruptura a nivel mundial que está
provocando este conflicto en ucrania
se está logrando
y en efecto pienso que en ucrania es la
estrategia de putin una nueva invasión a
ucrania por el momento depende de
quebrantar la voluntad del lado
occidental de la coalición dental en
apoyo a ucrania y los casinos de
diversas maneras como spinning and all
access para energía
escribiendo el acceso mundial
ya no siempre utilizan test tanto de
industria como de ucrania
intentando encontrar todas las pistolas
posibles
y es que a la mental o el momento en
efecto el cual es el occidental se
mantiene unidad y abogados hay muchos de
los
que anteriormente tuvieron como pegar
respecto al respecto
o por lo menos podemos deducir que el
extracto contando con el tiempo está de
su lado
o no
militarmente las situaciones más
complejas que ellos o el momento es una
caída de
ambos intentan pensar localmente
descargando la voluntad y la capacidad
de seguir luchando y
buscando
la lucha en el plano según cambio el
canto de la escuela también cambiar en
los puestos objetivos políticos
a ambos lados y objetivos de corto plazo
que puedan si obtener gas iván continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
en algunas declaraciones que ha dado el
presidente putin el habla de un mundo
que en esta altura en el momento de la
coyuntura en el que estamos es un mundo
unipolar el mundo en este momento es un
mundo unipolar en donde eeuu es el país
que lidera o porque se hablaba de un
mundo multipolar se hablaba de ser
rompimiento de la bipolaridad que había
cuando cayó la unión soviética y se
terminó la guerra fría se está hablando
de un mundo unipolar en este momento y
porque rusia lo ve de una forma unipolar
simplemente porque las condiciones no
juegan a favor de ellos
tienes que la la guerra que hoy estamos
viendo y varias transformaciones el 30 y
nacional que han estado han estado
acumulando en efecto nos empujan a un
mundo distante que vivimos 12 12 décadas
el mundo unipolar donde la supremacía de
estados unidos se hace tangible
el mundo pienso que el mundo en que
entramos no es el mundo multipolar
putin habla tiene sobre eso mundo
la coalición occidental eeuu van a
escribir en un primer gesto pero vale
más y más países con capacidad de ver
cambiar en las compras locales o
regionales
según sus intereses y sus valores vamos
a la potencia occidental va a mantenerse
como una agencia
de la guerra
para un mundo multipolar
así la opinión de estas palabras que
dice el presidente putin un mundo
unipolar y también está la opinión de
iván usted ya mencionaba que aquí se
estaban armando prácticamente dos
bloques cuál es entonces su opinión
profundizar por favor bueno
podemos decir que en términos del
poderío militar y también hasta cierto
punto podría económico en cuanto a
recursos por ejemplo energéticos irán
con su gas natural su petróleo aún con
las dificultades de exportarlo y rusia
con sus grandes recursos
naturales también pues hay digamos que
un una cuestión de multipolaridad en
cuanto a focos por ejemplo de
resistencia a eeuu pienso en irán pienso
en corea del norte pienso en la china
como rival pero también es socio no hay
que olvidar lo socio comercial
de eeuu la otra cara de la moneda rusia
ahora enfrentada completamente occidente
en ese sentido podemos decir que hay una
multipolaridad pero y claro a mención de
otras cosas como el brics no este bloque
geopolítico con en brasil rusia india
china sudáfrica quieren admitir ahora
argentina pero por ejemplo argentina que
tiene muchos recursos pero anda en una
situación económica muy precaria o sea
que hay que ver también no pueden ser
países muy grandes con mucha población
muchos recursos pero no tienen quizá el
mismo poder económico y por otro lado
pienso que quizás es todavía un mundo
unipolar en lo financiero en lo
monetario porque está el tema de la
subida de las tasas de interés por la
reserva federal el banco central de eeuu
que ha hecho que el dólar adquiera más
valor pero que también la libra
esterlina el caso de los británicos
entonces qué ocurre que las monedas de
otros países como países en sudamérica
tengo entendido el precio del peso
colombiano en chile también el peso y no
han caído ante el dólar el dólar atrae
más inversión de inversionistas del
mundo y las monedas nacionales de países
importantes pues adquieren menos valor
adquisitivo y eso que obtenemos la
inflación el alto precio las
importaciones o sea que por esos efectos
macroeconómicos
de que no se puede decir que bueno eeuu
está moviendo los hilos y está obligando
que las monedas bajen no es el mercado
el mercado y ante esos efectos diré que
todavía el dólar a pesar que putin y la
china están intentando irán también de
no utilizar el dólar en sus
transacciones
y el brics me parece que el segundo
objetivo de algunos de sus miembros no
de tener transacciones con otra moneda
que no sea el dólar lardero así el dólar
tiene pesos o sea que diría que depende
qué dimensiones estamos hablando en el
término monetario diría que todavía es
bastante unipolar quizá no es puramente
bipolar pero tiene bastante peso en
términos geopolíticos militares hay una
multipolaridad y claro hay una
bipolaridad diría yo que se están acabó
ya se están formando entre esos dos
bloques el bloqueo atlántico que incluye
también australia japón singapur diría
yo taiwán corea del sur o otros aliados
y está claro el bloque que yo le llamo
el bloque continental euroasiático las
potencias marítimas versus las potencias
continentales del viejo mundo se
interesante ese punto las paso a
preguntarle a iván en en estonia en cómo
podría ser dependiendo del análisis que
usted pueda hacer al respecto ese orden
mundial que está buscando rusia como
puede ser ese orden ideal que tiene
moscú que supuestamente está tratando de
promover de lograr de fomentar cómo
serían ahí las cargas
desde hace ya varias décadas por lo
menos dos ante todo lo acuerdo el
gobierno de putin moscú ha estado
promoviendo la idea de un mundo
multipolar en el que
hay un básico para sacar y base de las
acciones internacionales
pegadas a
la onu ante todo
realmente el pueblo del mundo está
gobernado a través de las grandes
potencias sus regiones inmediatas
rusia sería la primera potencia en toda
asia digamos el espacio euroasiático
europa y asia china sería la potencia en
el este asiático
y podemos seguir pensando de esta manera
eeuu en américa
no obstante esta visión de
la visión es promovida por él
bajo la idea que sea un orden más
democrático porque según ellos no sería
gobernado desde novio más exportadas
desde occidente no obstante hay que
pensar en lo que un mundo así serían
gobernado por
potencias regionales y un recurso sin
que los países más pequeños y más
de los países más pequeños quedaría nada
mercedes por potencias regionales
lo que obviamente con el caso de ucrania
pero no solamente en el caso de georgia
un país que estuvo en guerra con el
2008 y los demás ejemplos
por ejemplo tienen más de un régimen
internacional con algunas reglas y
órdenes en la participación de otros
países
y para terminar de construir esta
estructura de este supuesto orden
mundial que busca rusia que otros
componentes añadiría usted en resumen y
van ve como unas potencias regionales
que controlan los países de periferia es
un poco los movimientos que ha hecho
rusia tratando siempre de gobernar de
una manera rígida y de mantener su zona
de influencia sobre todo en las ex
repúblicas vemos países que pese a que
son independientes
alrededor de rusia siguen siendo muy
dependientes en muchas cosas de moscú
tipo de tayikistán armenia después de la
guerra de nagorno karabakh depende de su
defensa prácticamente para porque está
entre turquía y azerbaiyán en el mismo
caso de kazakhstán que no logra todavía
abrirse del toda europa porque rusia
siempre se pone en el medio como lo ve
usted
bueno es una situación en la cual hay
una rivalidad ahora yo yo pienso que se
va a intensificar pero es solo mi
especulación ahora la atención se centra
en ucrania y claro la entrada de
moldavia moldova en la unión europea e
incluir a georgia también sobre todo
después de la guerra en la invasión rusa
del 2008
y claro ha mencionado asia central hay
uno diría que está firmemente el control
de rusia pero también la influencia
china por ejemplo la organización de
cooperación de shanghai pero al mismo
tiempo
habría que pensar la situación rusa que
va a pasar porque de momento la guerra
hay una guerra de ucrania yo diría que
esa guerra es la otan a través de
ucrania lo apoyando a los ucranianos
contra rusia porque al autor no le
conviene que rusia se trague a ucrania
que es la intención en mi opinión de
vladimir putin por otro lado está pues
la cuestión de bielorrusia que va a ser
el lukachenko
en mi opinión pues aliado de rusia va a
putin influenciar le para atacar a los
países bálticos lituania todo tratar de
cortar la brecha de su malki que conecta
a polonia con lituani con el resto los
países bálticos y puedes conectar
bielorrusia con kaliningrado a la
antigua con expert producción entrada
alemana y eso claro sería una guerra con
la otan
no sabemos quiero decir que va a pasar
esta guerra se va a extender a una
tercera guerra mundial con fase
convencional y después que puede escalar
a una nuclear no se sabe en ese sentido
pero podría llegar a ocurrir que si
llega a colapsar el poder del estado
ruso
económicamente porque no tiene acceso a
altas tecnologías bueno al menos
occidentales los chinos probablemente
les proporcionaran y en la india también
pero si llegara especulando a colapsar
por su aislamiento del estado ruso
y acaso la los países de asia central
como kazajistán uzbekistán kirguistán
türkmenistán
querrían a través del mar caspio tratar
de iu a través de turquía y tener acceso
a pues ese bloque euroatlántico al menos
como asociados y tiene una política muy
independiente y si la cosa orbán de ser
el primer ministro húngaro de ser muy
pro ruso pero es miembro de una
asociación de naciones turcas que ahora
el nombre exacto se me escapa que
erdogán pues el presidente turco es
también miembro turquía
así que acaso y no olvidemos erdogán
tiene su agenda el comer si es de la
otan pero está también bailando pues al
son de lo que le convenga le compra
petróleo gas a rusia pero al mismo
tiempo le vende los va a estar tv dos
aviones no tripulados armados a ucrania
así que turquía habría que ver también
qué pasa en ese ámbito no pueden haber
cambios de alianza que las potencias de
asia central o los países se sientan
atrapados entre rusia y china
otro escenario el último punto esta
cuestión no es solamente esta globalidad
geopolítica puramente de poder económico
energético militar es también ideológico
porque en mi opinión aunque no sea
perfecto el bloggero atlántico
representa la democracia liberar la
economía capitalista de mercado el libre
mercado o el mercado en cambio quien
representa la democracia han
administrada lo llaman es democracia
china pues es una dictadura comunista
irán pues la democracia administrada una
peor gracia a los ayatolás sí así que
hay dos bloques en lo político en lo
económico y las de estados también
justamente esa era mi siguiente pregunta
qué es lo que ofrece en moscú porque
pues se habla socialmente es un país que
conozco en el que viví es una sociedad
donde hay muchos reclamos de libertades
donde hay muchas minorías que en cierta
forma todavía moscú controla y reprime y
ahí quiero hacer un apunte con respecto
a lo que usted dice de turquía turquía
ha ganado muchas posiciones
más allá de los pueblos turcófonos
tiene una gran presencia en el cáucaso
en las repúblicas
turcos o nada se está hablando de
chechenia ingushetia en donde
culturalmente se relacionan más con
turquía pero pues dependen políticamente
de moscú por ser parte de la federación
pero hay turquía va ganando terreno
también metiéndoselo un poco de las
fronteras a rusia en la pregunta
entonces iba a lo que ofrece rusia
porque eeuu ofrece este mundo de la
democracia la libertad la unión europea
de estos respetos de valores pero que lo
que ofrece rusia en este mundo
multipolar o unipolar o como ellos lo
quieran llamar que es lo que ofrece
rusia lados muy puntual por favor
el bueno el dominio del estado pero un
estado dominado por una minoría en este
caso el aparato de inteligencia y
seguridad la ex calle de ellos son los
que mandan incluso sobre las fuerzas
armadas que las tienen penetradas con
informantes y en el caso la china el
partido comunista usando las nuevas
tecnologías de la información y
comunicación para controlar mejor a la
población o sea que básicamente es una
actitud que no podemos dejarlo al
público al electorado a decidir
democráticamente porque pienso que esta
gente como putin temen que si se lo
permiten al autor al pueblo ruso o los
ciudadanos la federación rusa a votar
tatarstán se haría independiente y sería
independiente no quieren que le pase a
la federación rusa y gran temor de boris
yeltsin también lo que le pasó a la
unión soviética entonces tiene que
controlar a la población y ellos
consideran que son los únicos que saben
aparte lo último las joyas de la corona
rusa económicas son los grandes
conglomerados estatales como gazprom y
por ejemplo por rosneft
y rostekhnologii tecnologías militares
del complejo militar-industrial si lo
privatizarán el gobierno perdería el
control de esas cuya gran corona o la
mica rusa es otra y dior filosofía no
hay el libre mercado y la libre empresa
es elegir la disco duro si ya vimos el
intento de chechenia por la
independencia le costó dos guerras
contra moscú una invasión a su
territorio y tropas y bueno en miles de
vidas allí perdidas en chechenia cuando
hubo un intento de separación de la
federación iban su percepción de lo que
puede ofrecer rusia y le extiende un
poco la pregunta para avanzar con otros
temas el papel que puede tener china en
este orden mundial porque aquí
claramente se están chocando dos países
que quieren liderar al nivel mundial
está beijing y moscú compitiendo si
apuestan por un orden mundial diferente
pero llegará un momento en que los dos
van a estar peleando por ese liderazgo
en este sentido estoy totalmente de
acuerdo que el mundo del estado sigue
siendo unipolar en el aspecto mental de
la hegemonía del dólar
ha dicho eso hay cosas que lucía
hablando de ellos específicamente por el
momento
varios países del mundo que por el
momento no pueden encontrar en la actual
misión occidental o en estados unidos o
en otros lugares es ante todo un aparato
de seguridad una operación de defensa
que puede
en bani las sanciones occidentales o
el baño y un régimen de derechos humanos
podemos con ciertos países en áfrica
ante todo que
acceden a una cooperación estrecha con
los servicios de seguridad de grupos o
con compañías privadas bien se negocia y
que trabajan por operación de los
servicios de inteligencia de usos y
ofrecer una seguridad unos aparatos de
seguridad y defensa que van a dar
seguridad a los regímenes autoritarios
que los contratan esto es una parte muy
importante de la hoja de ruta y tiene
que ver con esta perspectiva de valores
y normativa que moscú tiene el aspecto
del mundo real
es una parte esencial del
principal encuentro binner un modo en un
mundo multipolar el caso de china hay
bastante que se ha especulado bastante
al respecto de lo que realmente puede
estar
la iniciativa
internacional de varios países
entonces eso ya fue un despliegue de una
gran capacidad que nos llega desde
beijing pero sus efectos y sus
resultados concretos en términos de
reemplazar los
accidentes en términos financieros no
han llegado a verdaderamente desplazar
los pecados internacionales
iban y en qué papel puede estar o qué
rol puede estar jugando américa latina
en estado en en américa latina eeuu ha
cedido mucho terreno a nivel de
influencia y por ejemplo el socio
comercial principal de la región ya no
es eeuu sino que es china
en ese orden mundial que propone rusia
como entraría nuestra región
pienso que américa latina pensando eso y
américa latina no ha logrado manejar con
una voz explicó la coyuntura actual en
europa
aunque sus valores están
el modo implicados en la guerra actual
especialmente en el valor de 90
organizaciones perfeccionar la soberanía
de un país
esta división
tiene consecuencias al respecto de cómo
américa latina se relaciona con
la vanidad estratégica de las ganancias
de hoy algunos países fijan masas
washington y europa a algunos más hacia
una industria y ahora un concepto de
este modo pienso que un análisis
para américa no va a depender mucho de
la dirección los gobiernos de la región
se me va acabando ya el tiempo el
programa entró al último bloque
en ese orden mundial que plantea moscú
que intenta lograr en usted ve que esto
va a ser como una especie de sistemas
como ustedes decían unas potencias que
controlan países de la periferia pero
van a ser estos bloques individuales
cada uno por su lado o habrá una especie
de relación entre ellos el
relacionamiento entre estos diferentes
bloques como lo vio usted tiene que
haber algún tipo de interacción porque
ninguno está completamente aislado y por
ejemplo rusia le vende petróleo
que tiene buenas relaciones con eeuu por
ejemplo
le comprar más a rusia
la china pues es el gran aliado diría yo
estratégico de rusia pero es el gran
socio comercial que tiene el principal
diría yo sí de eeuu hay una rivalidad
militar en la zona del océano pacífico
occidental con eeuu la cuestión de
formosa taiwán el mar el mar sur de la
china etcétera la libertad de navegación
pero al mismo tiempo y estrechas
relaciones comerciales pero podría ser
especulando que si el aislamiento ruso
sigue porque la guerra sigue y no se
resuelve que en ucrania se apueste a un
game qin gang yo pienso que a la larga
si lo está le ayuda y sigue ayudando a
ucrania puede ganar ucrania esa guerra
pero declaró rusia no es un país pequeño
tiene muchos recursos y tiene un
poderoso aliado la china podría haber
acaso que se forme una especie de dúo
dinámico
euroasiático rusia y china- china se
beneficia la vastos recursos minerales
energéticos y el gas petróleo en el
ártico por ejemplo en siberia en
numerosos recursos de la disposición del
dinero chino en tecnología china para
los rusos etcétera
y al mismo tiempo tienen planes creo que
de crear una base lunar conjunta rusia y
china- la nasa acaba de decir que teme
las ambiciones de la china de tener una
presencia en la luna en nuestro satélite
espacial para proteger la tierra de
ataque y asteroides o de meteoritos o
cosas porque temen que entonces la china
puede decir que la luna les pertenece o
sea que esa rivalidad que ahora vemos n
en nuestro planeta por la guerra de
ucrania es todo bloques como yo lo veo
que se están formando si podría llegar a
asaltar espacio exterior claves que
adelantando un poco en los
acontecimientos del futuro claro
colisiones en la red es posible con la
migración pero al mismo tiempo hay
rivalidad
puede terminar con una tercera guerra
mundial en que involucra ambos bloques y
la que ocurra el último punto la
diáspora del programa este se extiende
mucho por favor es que me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar y tengo que hacer
la conclusión y no es justo tampoco con
iván que tenga menos tiempo para
expresar sus opiniones voy llegando
entonces al bloques a la parte final se
me quedan varios puntos por fuera que
quería tratar pero iván su conclusión de
imaginemos el escenario de diciembre
2022 invierno en el hemisferio norte
europa sin gas de rusia toda la crisis
energética que está por empezar debido a
la falta del suministro y no sabremos si
habrán salido de los puertos ucranianos
todas esas toneladas de cereales y de
granos que estaban por salir de este
verano hacia el resto del mundo como
parte de esa cosecha en ucrania logró
putin poner a europa un poco entre la
espada y la pared para final de año
cualquier escenario y usted para
diciembre de este año
y
pero de un adicto más ya
europa
y sin precedentes lo hemos visto en la
diplomacia por ejemplo
entre los miembros de la unión europea y
con arabia saudita y estrictamente
lo hemos visto en las reuniones de la
unión europea
al cobrar o disminuir el gasto de
energía
las pérdidas
incluso proyectos
estuvieron abandonados cuántos años
volver a la vida como grandes proyectos
de empresas
energéticas conectando el badri casa
natural la energética de áfrica con
europa
la situación más inmediata es una
es un intento de resolver el efecto
laguna muy difícil de apagar el invierno
en el que los precios de energía van a
billy se van a mantener altos afectando
a todos los sectores de todas las
sociedades europeas si uno es más de
todos puede ser unos más que otros pero
no habrá ningún país que va a renovar
al perjudicado por estar en un escenario
complicado porque la unión europea le
sigue apostando a la diplomacia de las
sanciones y rusia prácticamente no ve a
la unión europea como un interlocutor en
este conflicto prefiere relacionarse
directamente con washington hablar
directamente con estados unidos o con
ucrania oa través de turquía que ver a
la unión europea como un interlocutor
ahí hay un problema de comunicación
entre las partes layos un minuto por
favor para la conclusión del programa de
cómo puede ser este escenario a final de
año cómo va a estar el mundo vamos a
estar con la inflación disparada vamos a
estar con un incremento en los precios y
rusia frotándose las manos logró
ponernos de rodillas
bueno el caso de alemania que es el
corazón de la unión europea
económico que se dice que puede aumentar
tres veces o aumentar a triplicarse el
valor de las cosas si no me equivoco no
la inflación y aumentar terriblemente
carestía de gas natural se acusa por
ejemplo a
angela merkel de haber dependido
demasiado el gas ruso pero una cosa eeuu
empiece a exportar más gas licuado catar
también el gol de los países árabes de
la península árabiga exportando petróleo
a través de egipto por el canal de suez
y met south creo que es que no sé si es
ese un oleoducto que conecta el mar rojo
con alejandría en egipto para europa
otra cosa esto va a impulsar y aunque se
sufra y tengan limitaciones el cambio
energía renovada renovable sobre todo el
hidrógeno que es y creo que alemania va
a apostar mucho a eso todavía se está
cambiado pero vaya a luchar y eso va a
ayudar a la cuestión de lo del cambio
climático este alegre sentido puede
tener una cosa positiva playas muchas
gracias y van en la ciudad de tartu
estonia les agradezco por haber hecho
este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 me despido rápido tengo que
dar paso al informativo gracias por la
sintonía sigan con nosotros
[Música]